estamos ad portas no sólo de normalizar
las relaciones diplomáticas sino las
relaciones consulares sino el paso por
la frontera el transporte entre norte de
santander y táchira sino la recuperación
de las condiciones de seguridad
necesarias y que tanto ha sufrido la
frontera
o la de toda la suerte
[Música]
yo asumo con mucha humildad y
responsabilidad el compromiso que me
instruye el presidente de la república
nicolás maduro modo el pueblo de
venezuela
[Música]
no era mi candidato preferido pero
queremos que lo haga bien sobre todo
aquí en la zona de los números y estamos
bastante unidos
de que lo haga bien que para que
colombia y venezuela tengan prosperidad
[Música]